[Music]  it's cold  Jessie's too used to the beach hey  Islander what can I say  look even the seas turning to ice  Wow  [Music]  a walking talking snowman you really are  alive  hello Olaf are these our friends hmm  nope never met him  don't know anyone blue green or without  the spike  [Applause]  yeah  give me strength  [Music]  whoa yeah  [Music]  take this  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  No  that's amazing you can control ice  control it  no all I ever do is hurt people this is  my home now I can't go back I don't want  to hurt anyone Roxas does exist his  hearts inside my heart the other  Twilight town is just data so what will  Elsa accept light or darkness I know I  want to know well good for you but guess  what I won't let her fall to darkness  [Music]  this Keyblade is that Mickey you're too  late  [Music]  you